And, as we're about to show you,
They delivered...
Big time!
[Awkward Laughing]
Ha.....
[Crowd cheers and claps]
[Man on the right]: ...Well, thank you team.
*snif*
*silence*
*laughter*
[Someone in the crowd]: WOO!
[Someone in the crowd]: "YEAH!"
YEAH!!
Huehuehuehuehuehue
A moment of....Excitement.
A moment of hype
Every year: "What games...
are they gonna announce?
What trailer? What new footage are they gonna show us?
Oh boy, I sure love knowing more about where
I am going to spend 60 dollars
on an over hyped product.
OH WAIT I CANT WAIT!!!
That's what a moron would say. A man of true culture, true intellect only cares about that snap
That's right cringe compilation everybody.
Hooray. We're back from last year
I feel like I have barely recovered from last year. My god
[Jesse Wellens]: Ehm, if you guys didn't know need for speed: payback, I'm b-
uhhmmm
*silence and chuckling, then cheering*
Yes, great game
[Pewd's chuckle] oh my god...
oh. Sadly we didn't get as, you know,
nothing's gonna beat Jesse's, dammit.
But why do-... We begin with the EA cringe they delivered wonderfully this year
I must say
GOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
OOOAL!
It's a goal!
Why is this guy still hired? I don't want people to get fired
*chuckles*
Every year he's back. I don't know why
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
It's like that one guy at a party that
You just want-- I'm being too mean here. Sorry
Like that one guy that you don't want to talk to at a party. That's just what the vibe I'm getting
I'm sure he's a lovely fellow it's just the vibe I'm getting, alright?
They [EA] had a wonderful little private booth area
That seemed really cool at the EA
About nine months ago we said "what do we want to do?"
and we were thinking: maybe we have a tent in the corner for our access members we
We hand out some water and then nine months pass and it's a three-story structure with the rooftop deck
[InterviewerI I mean, certainly an upgrade from a water tent that is for sure!
So who are the folks that are gonna be able to come into the access lounge?
We're not exclusive so everyone is welcome to come up to the access lounge.
Wow, wow, the access lounge... Yeah
[Sarcastic Poods] That looks good. That looks really nice.
Sheesh I sure wish I could be allowed in the access' lounge.
You know, they paid thousands of dollars for this.
*chuckle*
Oh my god.
[Interviewed woman] Some games set out that we're gonna have from our library, the vaults, we do have water!
We also have power for your phone.
I just, I was just about to ask. I'm really glad
They had that.
woman: dude, they got all kinds of free stuff!
guy: there's all kinds of stuff, there's not even just games!
There's trivia, there's prizes there's a ball pit... a ball pit, what? yep!
Oh my god. I didn't think they would top their
*wheeze*
The lounge area but they have a ball pit. ''What? Yep?'' Damn. ''Yep!'' Now I really regret not flying to LA. Dammit
So what's the deal with this belt?
So in my Madden League when you win a championship, you got to show off your championship
So I got the belt so everybody knows I'm the champ
NO ONE CARES
Oh
Hello, sometimes you have to stop and smell the roses here at the flower wall
We'll just stop sorry. Sorry
I'm just being... I'm bullying now.
''Now that's what this is all about. Removing harassment from gaming.''
OOOOOOOOOOOOO
Alright, we get it Felix, stop bullying. Okay, let's move on to the actual EA conference
[woman] Then we've got two new indie games to share and then I'm gonna come back towards the end of the show with some of my
favorite developers to give you guys a nice meaty look at anthem. And of course
[crowd]: WOO!
Yeah, we got the woos for anthem. I'm into it. You want, you wanna do this with me?
[hysterical laugh]
well it wouldn't be fun you guys, if I-
[Pewds cringing]
You want, you wanna do this with me?
*laugh*
Why would she ask that? I don't get it.
Give him a break he needs to just enjoy the show
[dev] As part of our portrayal of the second world war
"our portrayal of the second world war" everybody
It's just a portrayal guys, our portray-
It's a portrait of history, how we perceive history, how we wanted history to go down basically
[dev] We want to know more about our take on the Second World War
Your take on the second world war..
there's no take,
you can't just change battles. Am I crazy for thinking this?
I'm not even like, I don't even care about the whole sex issue or whatever
Yeah, I realize I sound like one of those mole rats
[dev] you will all go on an expanding journey through the Second World War
no loot boxes
no premium pass
*audience cheering*
It's kind of sad how that has to have a cheer to it, you know
You'll get something I know a lot of you have been asking for
Mm-hmm. It's
Royale
[crowd woos, boos and claps]
People literally booing
[claps and boos]
Yes, everyone wants another Royale
Wow, what a shocker
The whole E3 is basically just "oh we're working on a battle Royale guys. It's coming soon"
"Please don't burn yourself out on fortnite"
[woman]: and I just happened to find Mr. Vince Zampella here in the audience!
What's going on Vince how you feeling today?
[Vince]: I'm feeling great. I love this stuff. I love seeing new games
I mean someone's super excited about that event on PC, right? Yeah!!! [one woo from the audience]
[pewds cackling]
If I ever did a live thing I will never
Make the audience cheer, cuz it's just so painful if they don't
I mean someone's super excited about that men on PC, right? Yeah
[one woo]
''Mission failed''
Amazing, what a match! Thank you so much. That was awesome! Any thoughts guys?
I just came to make mammoth tanks. So I've done my job.
-"Any thoughts? What do you think?"
-"I just want to get off stage now. please".
so you guys would be, unfortunately,
out of the game now.
[player:] so we don't actually get to play anymore?
*pewds chuckles*
You thought I wouldn't notice that handshake? Pfft!
Let's move on to Sony's conference. Yay
Did no one play the DLC? Everyone seems to make a big deal that they kissed
It's already happened if there's one thing to be upset about is how Ellie looks so ugly now
Sony's press conference was interesting. It was about 2% games and 98% just music
*calm banjo music*
My favorite music performance out of the Sony E3 was the flute guy. It was beautiful
*off-tune squeaky flute*
*second off-tune squeaky flute joins in*
Ubisoft's conference can be summarized with one clip
*rock music*
[cheers]
[claps and scattered woos]
*rock music*
Ahhhh! blrrghh
ohhhh..
*rock music still playing while man groans*
Oh my god, did you see the guy that fell at the Ubisoft conference? Oh my god, do you think he got hurt?
I hope he didn't get hurt from that.
Announcer: ... FOR WK!!
oh yes. huhuhuhuhuhuhhuuhuhhuhuh!!!!
The most high performance ever. it's not a bad performance but... the audience isn't really there
*guitar, drums and a bit of a wacky piano playing*
*pewds laughs*
But then finally
The man, the myth, the legend: Todd Howard came out and he saved the whole conference
Todd announced that the new Fallout game is going to be an online game, which seems like a great idea
Online games are hard. They can have some nasty issues.
I read on the internet that our games have had a few bugs.
[crowd laughs]
hey!
*pewds laughing, bear roaring*
I read it on the internet, so it's true.
Okay, so that was it for E3 this year
so many games to be excited about
Now for real I think it's fun to see at least what new games are coming up
but there's always so much hype around these games, you know.
All these companies try and make you excited
they talk about the games literally years before they're even confirmed when they're gonna actually come out
I don't know how many times I've been hyped for a game in the past and it just turned out to be pretty mediocre
I mean, it happens all the time, you get sold the idea of a game and not really a game
And I don't really see a point in buying into the whole "Oh my god. That's so cool. I oh my god. I'm so excited" like
Play the game when they come out
Stop being so hype about things. It doesn't help anyone and that's it for me for now
Let me know if you enjoyed this video leave a like if you did hit the bell button and I see you guys tomorrow
That's right everybody! Big surprise. I'm gonna make a video tomorrow as well. Thank you everyone and I see you ahhh ey.
Oh Great, now, I did my own cringe. You're welcome everybody.
*Pewdiepie outro and OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO from the clip before mixed*